Hello everyone, I am Mircea, one of the other
TAs for this course and I will walk you through
using a Haskell editor online, if for whatever
reason, you don't want to install it on your
machine. In order to do this, you can go to
Google and search for FP Complete. It will
be the first hit. Then we go to Developers
and Build a project. We then create a new
project - you can do this without creating
an account if you don't want to. We give it
a name - new-project - and then create it.
You can see that there's already a template
with a default main function implemented which
just says "Welcome to FP Haskell Center".
You can run the project by clicking this small
arrow and you can see the output in the console.
Let's re-implement some of the functions you
have seen before. In order to do that we will
create a new module - we'll call it Test - and
save it. You can see that it will open in
the editor. Let's implement the double function,
which just adds x to x. In order to use this
function from the Main module, we will need
to import it - write "import test".
We'll have to wait for the type checker. Everything
went fine. Let's print the result. So double
takes an argument and adds it to itself, but
in order to print it we will need to first
convert it to a String and for that we will
use the Show function. Let's try to print
double 2. Wait for the type checker, run it
and we can see that we have the result.
Let's also implement the quadruple function by just
applying double twice.
Type checking went fine, so we'll go to main to print this as well.
We then run it and you can see that
we have the correct result. As a last function,
we will implement factorial.
Factorial is just the product of all numbers from 1 to n.
You can see that this type checks. We go to main..
and we'll print it again.
We then run it and we have the result
printed.
This is it! You can see it's very
easy. If you don't want to install anything,
there's also the online option available.
Thank you for your attention and keep on hacking!